I didn't really know what
entrepreneurship was but I believe that
necessity is the mother of invention
went out with those rocks she wouldn't
think that was cool they had no need for
people slammed the door me cussed me out
we see so many people living day to day
with so much money in popularity but
they haven't built inner wealth you know
people believe that opportunity knocks
you know once or twice or annually I
would say opportunity never knocks it's
something you have to go after with the
vengeance we're trying to be the next
this person or that person be the next
you because everybody else has taken
it's important to always be prepared I
would say if you stay ready you won't
have to get ready he's an American
businessman investor columnist author
and motivational speaker he began his
entrepreneur career at age six selling
homemade lotion and hand-painted rocks
at door-to-door he was named one of the
most influential black men in America by
the National Urban League he's Farah
gray and here is my take on his top ten
rules for success rule number five is my
personal favorite I'm really curious if
you grit which one you guys like the
most how did you know and how did you
have the wherewithal at that age that
young to start selling things I mean you
said you started selling rocks and
people like isn't that the rock that was
by my door and you sold it to them you
have the wherewithal to do something
like that in the courage well I think
that comfort is the enemy of achievement
growing up poor when I woke up my mom
was up when I went to sleep my mom was
up and my father was a black leader and
activist and activism doesn't come with
the salary so I realized I said wait a
minute my mom had a heart attack I said
I must do something to help her so I
went out and I sold oversized rocks that
I saw on the streets I would paint them
and I would ask people would you like to
buy this and people look at me like in
that the rock that was in front of my
door yeah and I would say yes but it
could be used as paperweights bookends
and door stoppers so I didn't really
know what entrepreneurship was but I
believed that necessity is the mother of
invention so I got out there and I tried
and I think that of course as grandma
says nothing beats a failure but a try I
was well introduced very early
- rejection but I went out with those
rocks some people didn't think that was
cool they had no need for people slammed
the door on me cussed me out all kind of
stuff but I just made a few dollars on
that door and then I said well let me go
to this one I made some money there but
the person in between customer yeah so
you know you kind of get a chance to see
very early but not everybody's gonna
tell you know a real Genaro someone who
was rich from the inside out we see so
many people living day to day with so
much money in popularity but they
haven't built inner wealth so we see
them getting pulled over for DUI is
going to jail living really I think on a
what I call a self sabotage mission but
what I've discovered is that you have to
balance the inner richness and the outer
richness and that's what a real Ian Ayre
is someone who is rich from the inside
out
most people say you have to be at the
right place at the right time I always
say no you have to be everywhere all the
time because your visibility is just as
important as your ability so I think you
have to show up and I find a lot of
times even personally people are just
not showing up anymore you can't win if
you don't play so we have to up for
example right now I find that people
aren't showing up for their
opportunities you know people believe
that opportunity knocks you know once or
twice or annually I would say
opportunity never knocks it's something
you have to go after with the vengeance
living in Las Vegas I even give credit
to people who you know hit the jackpot
there because at least they showed up
and put that dollar into the machine for
a chance so I think you have to give
yourself a chance and show up in your
relationship show up in your on your job
show up in life I had a teacher tell me
I told her I was gonna be a millionaire
entrepreneur one day I was 7 she looked
at me she said no you're not you're poor
and your family's poor you better go
find somebody to work for it she kind of
pointed towards make doesn't that make
you go hey wait a minute no no doesn't
that sort of empower you even more or
just give you the fuel to to prove that
person wrong well that 7 years old it
didn't I didn't know I'm going home to
my grandmother I said the teacher said I
wouldn't be successful I couldn't be
successful and she said remember that no
matter what anyone says to you wake up
every morning honey and she said and
said why not me if you want millions if
you want a mansion she said and
prophetically she said if you want to
put it into homelessness and I've been
the spokesman for the National Coalition
for the homeless when I found out that
the average age of a home
first was nine and a half years old I
knew that I could get back so she said
wake up and say why not me she said if
you believe in yourself you can
accomplish anything that you put your
mind to I had a guy he was 75 years old
he called and he cussed me out he said
for a gram I said yes he said I've been
working all my little life that I was
the cuss words President Harding cuss
I've been working all my life and why is
it that you have money far and I don't
I'm 75 years old I said because sir you
have to find what God puts you here to
do the richest place in the world is the
cemetery why because many of us have so
many gifts we're trying to be the next
this person or that person be the next
you because everybody else has taken you
have dreams you have seeds of greatness
within you you have the power to do
anything you want to do but you got to
put your mind in action so I realize
that there two fights
there's the fight to make the money and
then there's the fight to keep it we've
seen a lot of people hit the lottery
William blog post Evelyn Adams which I
talked about in my book and I get really
good rich they talked we were actually
focused on the fact that they made all
this money they announced it to the
world they talked about it and the next
thing you know they were broke your
people have won the lottery twice and
you know they live on public assistance
those two person has won is it a trailer
park and everyone's on public assistance
so it's really about studying what
others have done as soon as they made
money most people think that when you
can
television show your big break that
money that that film opportunity that
that's the time to relax I think it's
actually time to work harder and to
multiply your success and you need to
think I think four generations yet
unborn so I had several mentors the one
gentleman introduced to me numismatics
at an early age he said listen young man
you really want to make money he said
and have your children children
children's children thank you this is
what you need to do listen to me I said
okay yes sir I'll listen to you he said
follow my instructions invest your money
in gold silver and platinum I said
alright I did that a very early age so
it allowed me to really learn the
precious metals in the commodities
market you know I studied Berkshire
Hathaway you know back when it was
trading for a few thousand dollars a
share so I started making very strategic
investments because I realized yes I may
have this money now but what will happen
ten years from now ten years after that
and now I'm 29 years old
you know I've had great sustainability
and I can still call myself some of my
friends can't call himself that but I
can still call myself
by God's grace a multi-millionaire some
very thing you were the youngest member
on the Board of Advisors at the Las
Vegas Chamber of Commerce what kind of
pressure was that I mean to sit at this
it's a pretty big position right did you
feel prepared and worthy of being there
absolutely I think it's important to
always be prepared I would say if you
stay ready you won't have to get ready
yeah so being on the board of the Las
Vegas Chamber of Commerce basically gave
me a front-row seat of commerce and
business and also helping and assisting
in making decisions and of course some
people looked at me like isn't this kid
you know wasn't he born yesterday and I
would say yes I was born yesterday but I
stayed up all night a lot of times for
years and successful people have to
continue to sometimes to walk along you
know and operate to the beat of their
own drum yeah that's true keeping people
around you all right absolutely I would
say you know like the legendary rapper
Chuck D said if you can't change the
people around you change the people
around you I surround myself with good
people and some people are so negative I
would say they can walk into a dark room
and don't you gotta make sure you're
strong it's not good people that build
you up build that all-star team because
when you feel like maybe I can't do this
or I can't do that because one thing
that a lot of people don't understand
about success they ask me you know is
what you do difficult I tell them what I
do is easy I mean it is a piece of cake
the hardest part of what I do now was
the before it was believing that I could
do
and that's the key so when you have
people that encourage you that build you
up because a lot of times what they say
sinks into your subconscious mind a lot
of people say okay what do you mean by
subconscious mind we hear song on the
radio you know every single lyric to the
song but when it goes off you forget so
where were those lyrics they were your
subconscious mind your dreams something
saying it comes from your subconscious
mind so when you hear people say that
you're not smart enough you're not good
enough I had a teacher telling me that I
was too poor and I wasn't smart enough
to be an entrepreneur and recently she
called me cussed me out she did she said
why did you put my name in your book I
think I thought one of the exciting know
who you were so you couldn't crush
anyone else's dream and like one of the
Great's of our time once that never
allow anyone's perception of you to
become your reality what is it that we
do best I always say find your area of
excellence because the two most
important times I have learned is when
we were born and when we find out why we
were born what did God put you here to
do so ask yourself three questions first
question what comes easy to me but
harder to other people second question
what would I do and do it for free that
that one's tricky and the third question
is how can I be of service and how can I
give back and I believe that once you're
able to wrap those three things around
you and your philosophy the world the
marketplace will open up for your next
year your gifts and your talents thank
you guys so much for watching I made
this video because marceline be asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd also love to know what should the
top ten roles that we featured had the
biggest impact on you and why what are
you gonna change now in your business or
life because you watch this video leave
it in the comments and I will join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon